[Musique]
ce village qui farfal où s'est situé à
40 km de beyrouth
ici il ya deux jours nous étions en
train de tourner notre fils quand il y a
eu une explosion à beyrouth
[Musique]
mais je monte je
ni d'el milia une semaine nous sommes
arrivés dans ce village avec l'équipe de
tournage pour mes débuts en tant que
réalisatrice
c'est l'histoire d'une fille et d'un
petit village du banner qui déménage
dans une grande ville nous aurions dû
filmer la partie en vie dans une semaine
maintenant nous ne savons pas ce que
nous allons faire parce que certains des
lieux de tournage ont été détruits dans
cette maison et ce jumelage nous ont
sauvés le calendrier avait été élaboré
de façon à ce qu'on tourne d'abord dans
ce village l'explosion nous a surpris
1 40 km et de l'avion c'est ici qu'on
filmait au moment où on a entendu
l'explosion
nous avons tous couru par ici parce que
l'explosion avait lieu là bas nous avons
demandé à nos collègues libanais ce que
ça pouvait être ils ont répondu
tristement que probablement une guerre
avait comme ancien
[Musique]
de la première chose à laquelle j'ai
pensé c'est qu'il s'agissait d'une
attaque des israéliens sur le port
libanais le 4 août une énorme explosion
a eu lieu au port de beyrouth
plus de 150 personnes sont mortes et
environ 5000 ont été blessés
[Musique]
abbas et m
tout à coup on a senti une explosion
s'est effondré sur nos têtes
j'étais chez moi dans mon lit je
regardais la télé tout à coup la fenêtre
m'est tombé dessus
l'armoire nous est aussi tombé dessus ma
fille a été blessée au bras et a besoin
d'être opéré mon autre fille a aussi un
problème au bras
mac os il ne peut plus marcher j'ai des
coupures aux jambes
ma mère a été grièvement blessé un éclat
l'a touché à l'épaule et à l'oeil
[Musique]
l'explosion a presque complètement
détruit le port elle a été d'une telle
force qu'on a pu la comparer à la bombe
atomique de hiroshima
les hôpitaux de beyrouth sont débordés
et les autorités ont mobilisé tout le
personnel médical
en chine d'abord nous avons entendu une
petite explosion chimique quelque chose
brûlé il ya des gens que nous devions
partir à ce moment là je me suis tourné
vers le nord j'ai été touché au bras
droit
c'est là que la grande explosion l'a
fait tomber par terre
après la deuxième explosion
la dernière chose que j'ai vu c'était la
poussière et le verre qui pleuvaient sur
nos corps j'ai vu des restes de corps
sur le sol des gens qui criaient un des
enfants qui pleuraient à l'hôpital nous
avons accueilli plus de 300 blessés
maintenant dont quatre sont décédées de
personnes n'ont pas été identifiés ben
oui
[Musique]
la cause de l'explosion a été rapidement
déterminer environ deux mille sept cent
cinquante tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
stocké dans le port ont explosé ils ont
été confisqués en 2014 aux navires aux
us pendant six ans cette substance s'est
trouvée dans un entrepôt portuaire sans
aucune mesure de sécurité le chef du
service libanais des douanes a déclaré
que son agence avait demandé à plusieurs
reprises à la justice l'autorisation de
détruire la substance dangereuse mais
aucune mesure n'a été prise
aoka noc et comment peut-on stocker ce
type de substances dangereuses
je veux dire le volume stocké au port
était de deux mille sept cent cinquante
tonnes
ça n'était pas loin des gens ballon de
la zone résidentielle et de la zone
commerciale
pour moi ça a été un enfer il était une
explosion dévastatrice vraiment horrible
elle a détruit presque tous ici mon
immeuble
ma maison la plupart des immeubles de la
rue où j'habite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après l'explosion qui a frappé la ville
de beyrouth le gouvernement a déclaré
l'état d'urgence pour deux semaines
les secouristes sont toujours en train
de passer au crible les débris à la
recherche de survivants
mais le plus grand nombre de morts a été
recensé dans le port
les habitants de la ville se rassemblent
attendant désespérément des nouvelles de
leurs proches disparus des centaines de
personnes sont toujours portées
disparues
nous voulons retrouver les membres de
famille et partir qu'il soit vivant ou
mort peu importe ce qui leur est arrivé
nous voulons que nos enfants reviennent
ça fait trois jours que nous sommes ici
j'ai passé la nuit ici et j'ai l'état
doit nous retrouver notre fils vivant ou
mort nous n'avons aucune nouvelle de lui
depuis trois jours s'il était encore en
vie hier peut-être qu'il est mort
aujourd'hui ils ne l'ont pas sauvé un
véritable état l'aurait sauvé trois
jours déjà il se moque de nos enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardons ce qui est devenu notre lieu
de tournage ici nous avions prévu de
filmer l'appartement de notre
protagoniste les fenêtres et les portes
ont été soufflées je pense que tout
réparer prendra beaucoup de temps
[Musique]
une grande partie de la ville est en
ruines environ 300000 personnes n'ont
plus de maison
[Musique]
après m'appelle moi c'est dans cet hôtel
que nous séjournons il ya cinq jours
maintenant il est fermé comme vous voyez
tout est couvert de décombres il n'y a
plus de fenêtres
le mobilier cassé à l'ampleur de
l'explosion est évidente aujourd'hui en
est le 6 août les gens nettoient les
débris et c'est de remettre de l'ordre
dans leurs bureaux boutiques et
appartements
le problème est qu'il est impossible
d'acheter du verre à beyrouth
car il n'y a pas d' usine de verre aux
lits dont toutes les vitres sont
importés est actuellement à cause de la
crise du coc vie de 19
c'est presque impossible il y a trois
jours ces cafés proposés des petits
déjeuners déjeuners et dîners
maintenant ils sont tous fermés des
milliers de libanais sont descendus dans
la rue pour s'entraîner et se soutenir
dans cette situation difficile des gens
des quatre coins du liban qui sont venus
à beyrouth
l'ensemble de la population libanaise
comprend à quel catastrophe nous faisons
face ils se tiennent la main
centraide à dieu sait comme vous voyez
ils viennent nettoyer les rues les
bâtiments débloquer les rues puisque
nous avons vraiment besoin
les habitants du nord et du sud de la
baie cas nous ont contactés en disant
qu'il était prêt à ouvrir leur porte et
héberger les familles qui ont perdu
leurs maisons kahn a mangé dire nous
avons été touchés par l'explosion
vous avez vu l'étendue des destructions
et essayer de sauver des victimes nous
mêmes
il y avait des corps nous avons essayé
dont mais les gens à l'hôpital depuis ce
matin plus de 650 jeunes hommes et
femmes se sont portés volontaires et
sont descendus dans les rues de jamie
cgt oui et marc mirel les environs du
siège de l'électricité les jeunes gens
sont venus pour enlever le plus de
décombres possible sinon nous sommes ici
après la catastrophe qui nous a frappés
nous devons tous être ensemble s
entraider nous distribuons de la
nourriture à ceux qui en ont besoin et
qu'ils le désirent
[Applaudissements]
l'explosion a aussi endommagé les silos
à grains contenant les réserves
céréalières du liban laissant le pays
avec un mois de réserves le liban fait
donc face à une crise humanitaire et
alimentaire
la catastrophe a également provoqué des
manifestations anti-gouvernementales à
beyrouth
malheureusement chaque fois qu'on se dit
que c'est la pire situation qui pourrait
arriver au liban il arrive quelque chose
d' encore pire j'espère sincèrement que
c'est la fin de tout cela parce que
notre pays fait déjà face à des
problèmes économiques financiers et
sociaux et c'est désormais encore pire
car des milliards de dollars ont été
perdus en quelques secondes ça casse
j'espère et je crois sincèrement que
après toutes ces souffrances
le liban se remettra sur pied mais cela
exige de nous détermination une
stratégie claire et une vision nous
croyons tous en notre pays des libanais
peuvent se dresser ensemble et remettre
le liban en état comme il était avant et
poursuivre un avenir meilleur